alors avant que ça commence je voulais
pas un disclaimer ce que j'ai remarqué
que sur certains réseaux sociaux dès
qu'on parlait de communisme et
capitalisme ça donnait de suite très
tendu je rappelle donc que cette vidéo
c'est un coup de fil c'est à dire une
vidéo assez courtes qui a pour but
d'introduire des concepts mais avec des
vannes et des gags de petites saynètes
etc
voilà je pense qu'il faut le garder en
tête et c'est vide en fait ce que j'ai
je les ai mangés avant de tourner cette
scène de paris cela m'a empêché de les
manger
voilà ça commence you ses sirius est
bien dans le coup de fil vous trouvez
que vous êtes exploité par ôta tron vous
n'acceptez plus les inégalités de notre
société
vous ne supportez pas que votre livre
d'eli verrou se trompe dans votre
commande
bref vous en avez marre des dérives
capitalistes de notre monde aujourd'hui
sortez les marteau et faucille parce
qu'on va s'attaquer au capital de carbox
annoncé pas celui-là c'est l'autre karl
marx
il est né en 1818 facile à retenir en
allemagne et il a écrit beaucoup de
choses notamment un livre qui va nous
intéresser particulièrement et qui
s'appelle le capital alors il va nous
intéresser plus que les autres parce
qu'il a mis plus d'une quinzaine
d'années à l'écrire il avait prévu de le
faire en trois livres mais il n'a pu
écrire que le premier libre sur les 3
les deux autres ils ont été constitués à
partir de manuscrits qu'il a laissé donc
ça c'est un peu ça masterpiece qui
voulait d'ailleurs il dit lui-même dans
une lettre à un pote que c'est
certainement le plus redoutables
missiles qui était lancé à la tête de la
bourgeoisie badass à l'autre raison qui
fait qu'on va parler de ce livre c'est
que cette vidéo est faite en partenariat
avec kurokawa
c'est une maison d'édition qui vient de
lancer course avoir cédé mangane qui
reprennent un peu des oeuvres phares de
l'histoire de la philo c'est tout
nouveau et l'un des mangas c'est sur le
capital de marx où je me suis dit qu'on
va faire d'une pierre deux coups mais la
vraie raison c'est que c'est tellement
ironique que le seul coup de fil
sponsoriser ce soit celui sur marx que
j'ai pas pu refuser quoi elle les voyait
un coup de fil sur marx effet eu moorman
light air pur produit
passion revenant capitale comme vous
pouvez le voir c'est un très gros
bouquin est paradoxalement même si ça un
livre super important chez marx il est
assez peu lui déjà parce que c'est un
livre qui se lit pas vraiment mais qui
s'étudie sont clairement quand tu
arrives à la fin tu oublies le début
mais surtout parce que marx quand on s'y
intéresse généralement c'est pour deux
raisons la philosophie et la politique
or le capital de marx c'est plus un
livre d'économie mais vous allez voir
qu'ils nous aident quand même à
comprendre la pensée marxiste
cette pensée marxiste elle est imprégnée
d'une notion hyper importante c'est la
notion de lutte des classes en gros on a
d'un côté la classe capitaliste la
bourgeoisie et de l'autre on a la classe
des prolétaires les travailleurs les
prolétaires et sont dominés par les
capitalistes ils doivent donc
s'émanciper soto émancipé même puisque
la classe dominante
on va pas se laisser faire ils disent
qu'on aboutisse à une société sans
classes une société communiste est le
nerf dominated by capital one man et
sportives pour inspirer
des communistes but she wants you might
be more comme moi
il na tchuto des secours froc capitals
[Musique]
comment les bourgeois ils restent à leur
place de bourgeois et ben notamment
grâce à l'accumulation du capital
il accumule du capital de la tune on les
accumule de la thur et comment ils font
par différents procédés
mais celui qui va nous intéresser ici
c'est ce que marx appelle le surtravail
en gros dans sa journée
le travailleur il va à un moment donné
fournir plus de travail que nécessaire
du travail pour lequel il sera pas payé
c'est grâce à ça que le patron ou plutôt
le capitaliste peut générer de la plus
value cette plus value elle n'existe que
parce que le capitaliste paix - le
salarié que la valeur générée par son
travail et pour marx le patron ait
laissé payer ses salariés le moins
possible pour maximiser les profits
d'ailleurs pour lui le mot profit c'est
du politiquement correct pour parler
d'exploitation par le vote comptant la
fin de match par en vacances
ah ouais cool profil d'un pardon bas
profitent des vacances
je sais que c'était avec nous non mais
je suis avec vous je suis avec vous de
ouf je suis abonné médiapart je vais aux
manifs et je vais la fête de l'huma
aussi en tant que bénévole non saleté
capitaliste marque parle de sueur
travail mais parle évidemment aussi de
travail et pour lui le travail dans la
société capitaliste il et aline en
invoquant menu j ai fait une table il
termine sa table il voit son taf il
palpe mêmes et donc il comprend son
utilité il comprend son apport alors que
dans une usine de table ou ton job c'est
de mettre la vis pour le pied en bas à
gauche de la table as tu partages pas
trop le sentiment du menuisier quoi au
contraire pour marx tu te sent
dépossédée toi même ce que tu produis et
étrangers à toi on dit que tu es aliéné
par ton travail et d'ailleurs pour marx
c'est pire avec le progrès technique
puisqu'il dit que la facilité même du
travail aidés par la machine devient une
torture en ce sens que la machine ne
délivre pas l'ouvrier du travail mais
des pouilles le travail de son intérêt à
tous
bonjour bonjour alors aujourd'hui on va
voir comment construire une voiture
c'est très simple vous tenez bien droit
vous prenez votre doigt comme ceux ci et
vous avez sur bouton voilà très simple
on verra la semaine prochaine comment
construire une maison
merci beaucoup donc ces jobs là pour
marx ils sont aliénant mais ce n'est pas
tout ils ont une autre caractéristique
si vous mettez une vis pour le pied en
bas à gauche de la table et que vous ne
faites que ça mais en fait vous êtes
facilement remplaçable donc à une forme
d'insécurité lié à ces emplois voulais
pas qu'il écrit ça en 1867 et le droit
des travailleurs s'étaient pas trop ça
et je vous parle de travail mais ce qui
est intéressant dans ce que nous dit
marx c'est que parfois ce travail on le
voit pas quand on regarde une
marchandise donc n'importe quel objet
qu'on peut vendre ou acheter ou échanger
ou n'a l'impression de sa valeur elle
vient pas du travail et des rapports
sociaux et humains qui sont faits pour
la produire
mais qu'en fait elle a une valeur par
elle même pour marx la marchandise a là
un caractère mystique qui fait qu
indépendamment du travail nécessaire à
la produire
elle a une valeur par elle-même cette
illusion c'est ce que marx appelle le
fétichisme de la marchandise et ce
fétichisme
il montre qu'en fait dans la société
capitaliste dans la production
économique
elle échappe au contrôle des producteurs
elle suit ses propres lois c'est les
lois du marché et ses lois on y est
soumis comme si c'était extérieur alors
que ça vient de nous d'ailleurs marx
compare ça à la religion mais ce n'est
pas du tout le débat du jour
alors pour revenir rapidement sur le
manga du capital de marx j'ai surkiffé
que dans l'histoire
donc là en l'occurrence c'est l'histoire
d'un homme issu du prolétariat qui veut
vaincre le capitalisme mais qui en
devient la victime d'une manière assez
inattendue
il ya des planches avec des schémas des
explications et je trouve ça hyper bien
fait c'est très bien fait construit et
surtout j'espère que ça va donner envie
à plein de gens de s'intéresser à ces
problématiques là que soit marx ou
d'autres philosophes c'est un petit peu
mon but au début de cette chaîne est
avec cette émission le coup de fil et
donc forcément je ne peux que saluer
l'initiative jouer plus d'infos en
descriptions sur le manga et sur le
reste du love et de la pisse alors le
manga le capital de marx il sort
aujourd'hui le 12 septembre
mais ce n'est pas le seul il ya aussi
ainsi parlait zarathoustra de nietzsche
psychologie des foules de gustave lebon
et crime et châtiment de dostoïevski et
le 14 novembre il y as aphorismes sur la
crs dans la vie de schopenhauer et amour
luxe et capitalisme de son parc
en tout cas j'espère vraiment que cet
épisode vous a plu et n'hésitez pas à me
dire ce que vous en avez pensé dans les
commentaires